[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Полтавщина
Полтава]
Дизайн — це така річ,
яка зачіпає одне за іншим.
Ланцюжок. Ось ти щось, наприклад, зробив,
повісив — і розумієш, що чогось тут не вистачає.
Ти починаєш доробляти,
то туди гілочку, рисочку, цяточку.
[В'ячеслав Дерябін
Різьбяр]
У підсумку виходить композиція.
Деревом приємно дихати.
Люди полірують.
Але це не може бути схоже на дерево,
адже воно поліроване і гладжене.
Дерево має бути живе.
Воно має дихати, бути м'яке.
Ось поличка, у неї нема полірування.
Проте в неї є душа.
А тепер приставте її до будь-якої поверхні.
Все, ви не відведете від неї погляду.
Ви подивитесь на неї зранку,
коли питимете каву.
Подивитесь в обід,
коли прийдете поїсти борщу, і ввечері...
Погляд постійно буде прикутий
до цього предмета, тому що це дерево живе.
Воно має неправильну форму,
воно від природи.
Матеріал сам підсказує, що з ним зробити.
Я навіть не пам'ятаю, що зробив перше.
Якусь дрібничку.
Чотири роки назад збудував майстерню.
Тут був мій сарай.
Я взяв і виклав його по-іншому.
Взагалі я займався ландшафтним дизайном,
у мене дуже добре виходило.
Я був першим, хто цим займався у Полтаві.
Навчався у кооперативному технікумі,
все життя працював будівельником.
Я колишній боксер.
Брав участь у змаганнях серед юніорів і юнаків.
Але на дорослий рівень не вдалося вийти —
доля склалася інакше.
Я покинув місто на певний час.
Мене не було у Полтаві 25 років.
Перебував у в'язниці.
Хмельницька область.
Це було хуліганство,
сталася звичайна бійка.
Дякую долі, що все так минулося.
Навчився працювати руками.
Працювати токарем на станку,
навчився зварювати.
Багато чого навчився,
а пізніше зайнявся виробництвом.
Діабет...
Подряпав ногу і почав лікувати капустою.
Варто було одразу звернутися до лікаря.
Коли пішов до лікарні, було надто пізно.
Усі ми так робимо...
Ми так само кидаємо пити, палити,
ми так само одружуємось.
Коли справжня наречена образилась і пішла,
а потім дивишся, а тобі вже 40 років.
Потім тобі друзі радять одружитися
на першій ліпшій, ти одружуєшся.
Ти одружуєшся, а через рік з'ясовується, що одружився не з тією...
А та, що потрібна, була раніше.
Людина, яка живе...
Моє покоління...
Мені 60 років буде весною...
Восени... Взимку!
Наша людина чому завжди вважає,
що напис англійською
на виробі робить його міцнішим,
більш привабливим і якісним.
Тому що ми у третьому поколінні радянські люди
і ми звикли до того,
що як написано англійською,
то це має бути якісний продукт,
адже воно іноземне.
Серія називається «Forest», «Ліс».
Я знаю, що з англійської forest — це ліс,
а ліс це завжди добре!
Написав також російською «Монастырский лес»,
і воно має зовсім інший вигляд.
Мене цікавить сам процес.
Матеріал може бути будь-який.
До мене звертаються люди,
які говорять: «Зроби це, щоб було так»
або «Зроби сам, ми нічого не знаємо».
Тоді я їм говорю, щоб принесли
хоча б якийсь малюнок,
який ви б хотіли бачити на виробі.
Вони відповідають, що ні — роби сам,
адже все, що б ти не зробив, буде добрим.
Тоді я відчуваю відповідальність,
тому що я маю зробити так,
як ніхто ще не робив.
Щоб людина прийшла
і у неї не виникало запитань.
Щоб вона зрозуміла, що такого сама не намалює,
принаймні точно не такий самий малюнок.
Натхнення знаходжу у роботі,
приходжу і починаю працювати.
Головне — це напрямок.
Якщо людині цікаве ремесло,
вона хоче творити —
з'явиться бачення і все інше.
Головне працювати
і знати порядок роботи!
Я не вмію малювати.
Малював Північне море,
воно обов'язково має бути світле,
безмежне, холодне і непізнане.
Згори повинні бути «свинцеві» хмари.
Це Карл Брюллов «Вершниця».
Я зробив рамку до цієї картини,
одягнув цю жінку у раму.
Вона вийшла велична на коні.
Водночас вона вийшла скромна,
тому що сама рама її і приборкала.
Вистачить економістів і юристів,
адже народ у нас розумний і талановитий.
Навчайте працьовиту людину.
А зараз який час:
покласти плитку — не знайдеш нікого,
зварити частини металу — не знайдеш нікого.
Це поразка, яка коштуватиме нам десять років.
Треба людину психологічно підготувати,
щоб він навчився цього,
а вже потім працював у цьому напрямі.
Потрібно цілу країну навчити,
щоб були свої працівники.
Проте зараз люди виїздять
працювати до інших міст,
хоча кожен має працювати у себе вдома.
Мені шістдесят років.
Працюватиму скільки сил вистачить.
Це єдина мета життя, яку я маю.
Найголовніше для чоловіка — це ремесло.
Чоловік має працювати.
Для когось я вироблю стілець,
а хтось для мене виростить капусту.
Кожний займається своєю справою.
Тоді прийдуть зміни, європейське майбутнє
і все у нас буде добре.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Дмитро Охріменко, Павло Пашко]
[Продюсерки
Наталя Панченко, Наталя Курсик]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Fudo Kazuki, Tik Tu,
Endless Melancholy, Sasha Boole, Polly K]
[Субтитрувальник
Владислав Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]